Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do: No bets concerning XK-Class End of the
World Scenarios!
It's the one thing we hope to avoid: An XK
Class Scenario, an event that results in the
complete and utter destruction of the world.
Most of us prefer not to think about it at
all, unless we're actively trying to prevent
it.
Not Dr. Bright, though.
He sees the apocalypse as a chance to make
a quick buck!
Dr. Bright is officially prohibited from making,
accepting, or taking any rake-off bets related
to XK Class Scenarios.
These include, but are not limited to, "I'll
bet you a thousand bucks the robots get us
first," "it'll all start with ducks," and
"not with a bang, but with a whimper."